hey everybody I am Kristen Gill and I'm
here with the beautiful makeup artist
celebrity hair stylist Emma Willis hi
guys and we are going to do a bronzy
summer glow that all of her celebrity
clients have been wanting this summer
especially bachelor nations becca Tillie
i hope you guys enjoy let's get started
so first we are going to be moisturizing
the skin just mainly I like to keep it
kind of down the t-zone and just a
little bit under the eye area and around
the cheeks and I just like to dab it in
everyone always asks me about primers
and stuff like that I'm not a big fan I
don't use primers for eyes I use
concealer okay nothing like a little
trick and then we'll get started with
the illumination and the foundation and
I like to mix the products here okay so
when we mix in an illuminator with the
foundation so kind of give that real
glowy effect and I'm gonna mix two
foundations for your skin you've got and
really dump these guys no dry sponges no
no my gosh really rinse it well with
water and squeeze it and it will create
a flawless canvas for your skin the
sponges my jam I'm actually just adding
a little bit of extra illumination we've
got to talk about your agencies oh yeah
art work faster I came up the name many
many years ago of contour boss makers
wanting to create an agency down the
line and a brand and all the areas of
the face that's you contour all that are
contoured are called saucers now I'm
going to add a bit of concealer I don't
like to go around the nose area then I
take an extra brush and I buff it out
and I'll tend to like go in the lighter
concealer this is kind of a look that a
lot of my celebrity clients ask for I
work a lot with Becca Tilly and Jojo
Fletcher and I should green and things
like that and we bring out their eyes as
well as like that bronze summer glow I'm
concealing the eyelid and I take it all
the way up to the brow bone
going now with a little bit of cream
blush to the cheek and smile and I just
dug this on my finger how do you decide
where to put it when you smile you
really want to pop it on the apples of
the cheeks okay and so now I'll go in
with a little bit of bronzer to give
structure going into the face that's why
I like to Pat okay I'm a tap tap tap and
I'm half at Pat time because just add a
little bit of contour to the sockets
eyeshadow in the crease basically is
your yeah turn your eyes and smile and
it's gonna lightly dust now a little bit
of powder blush over the apples of the
cheek she's using Chrissy Teigen palette
yes I am and then I take the sponge and
I just give it a little bit of a dab
okay so I'm pushing through the brows so
I'm gonna go in with a bit of caramel
and angle brush okay so now I'm going in
with a darker bronzer and I'm gonna use
the majority that eye makeup I'm
actually going to use bronzers so this
one I'm just going to the sockets add a
bit more depth so I distribute the the
main amount of the product to the outer
edge and then I'm just buffing it into
the socket and then bringing it lip
slightly over the eyelid so what's one
of your favorite red carpet looks you've
ever done
winter Carson we just did one recently
further Radio Disney and we decided to
just do very luminous sheer eye on top
and then we decided to do like baby
pinks and like mode like under the eye
and then like loads of lashes I'm using
Becca's blushed copper it's a really
pretty blush and I'm going in over on
the eyelid with the same shadows I like
to bring it under the lower lash line
I'll go in with them on the waterline
with more like a deeper Brown but I'm
actually almost smudging it into the
roots of the lashes now I'm gonna go in
with a darker Brown just to the roots of
the lashes on top and you use a fan
brush I like to use a fan brush
underneath to catch anything fall out
I'm having some long and medium
individuals my favorite part highly okay
with a fan brush I'm gonna tap the brush
and go down the center of the nose and
then take it to the end I'm gonna go
across the lip here let's make it a
little bit here kind of a little bit
other pieces though and the dust just
belong and then just almost taping off
on to the apples of the cheeks this is
completely head by artist could sure Wow
I like to give a little pop and you can
also like press literally in the center
[Music]
okay I'm going in with a lip liner
called dirt news by rodeo and I like to
take the lip liner all over the lip and
with slightly over draw Kristin's top
lip stick a little bit more than I like
to add a pencil all over the entire lip
I feel like a it lasts longer be even if
the top topper that you apply or the
lipstick lip gloss or whatever you apply
you're still going to have remnants of
color on your lip no matter what
[Music]
okay I think we are absolutely sages
does that bronzy jewellery
yeah oh yeah this is beautiful look I'm
Beca telling what's up
[Music]